con cánticos aplausos y aclamada como
heroína fue recibida la escaladora elnas
recavi la madrugada de este miércoles en
el aeropuerto de Teherán la deportista
compitió en el campeonato de escalada
asiático en seúl la prenda que las
mujeres iraníes están obligadas a llevar
en público para cubrir su cabello un
hecho que Fue relacionado con las
protestas por la muerte de maxamney pero
la deportista ha asegurado que se debió
a un descuido
me llamaron inesperadamente y tenía que
competir estaba preocupada poniéndome
los zapatos y el equipo técnico Y eso
hizo que me olvidara de poner maquillaje
que tenía que usar luego fui a competir
regresé con plena salud y me disculpo
con el pueblo de Irán por la turbulencia
y la preocupación que les cree en seúl
se le vio entrar decididamente solo con
una diadema y el pelo recogido en una
coleta pero tras su Disculpa activistas
aseguran que fue obligada a retractarse
medios de comunicación En fase dijeron
que la deportista podría ser detenida y
que fue obligada a dejar Corea antes
previsto la embajada de la República
islámica de Irán en Corea del Sur niega
enérgicamente todas las noticias falsas
mentiras e información falsa sobre la
señora elnas recabi el acto de había
hecho eco en las manifestaciones que
sacuden al país hace más de un mes tras
la muerte de maxam Mini fallecida bajo
custodia policial tras haber sido
detenida por no llevar el hillab en
público las manifestaciones sin
precedentes sean extendido por todo el
país en exigencia de los derechos de las
mujeres y se han convertido en un
cuestionamiento a los cimientos del
régimen teocrático que rige el país